hey Ron you want me to read you what I
have so far my welcome letter nothing
because you and your jerk predecessors
didn't give me anything to work with did
you print this out I heard the printer
going yes you could have just handed me
a blank piece of paper Oh
wisdom finally thank you so much you can
also keep the photo thanks for the
memories
good god I don't remember this that's
the wrong one
the real ones very bad as well I want
you to know that I'm replacing the
Welcome letter with this ad for yearning
by Dennis Feinstein so goodbye distilled
wisdom of fifty years of experience
hello disgusting fragrance flap let me
buy you dinner no I insist do you buy me
dinner
when I become city manager my job is
yours of course my first act of city
manager will be to propose eliminating
the parks department although I expect a
spirited debate with Leslie who knows
what the future holds for me
maybe I'll leapfrog Ron's job and become
city manager of course my first act as
city manager would be to double the size
of the parks department although I do
expect a fight from run but I'll win
Thank You Darla why would anybody ever
eat anything besides breakfast food
people are idiots largely oh right and
clearances ancient junk
happy birthday run and said you had a
big party sombreros karaoke I did that
for an why would I throw around Swanson
an Ann Perkins party what about the
giant list of things April was doing
that was just a list of ways to mess
with you she do them all she did indeed
so I have rented Bridge on the River
Kwai and the Dirty Dozen arty from
security is outside the door so no one
will bother you and a cab will be here
whenever you're ready to take you home
thank you
Edna this watered-down baby formula
not even close not even close
Marvin clones Glenn Close Leslie you
don't have to do this go to bed Jimmy
why I can't feel everybody pants now
pants pants pants pants pants she said
enough call it off that's not how it
works she's out wait I'm subbing in
April no that stuff will melt the shell
off a garden snail I'm Porter eight I
can handle it okay
this ends now yeah
it's a nice chair Corinthian leather
solid mahogany frame with what I believe
her hand-cut mortise and tenon joints
pinned with oak it was really looking
forward to sitting in it
figured this might be my last chance you
don't know that Ron for the last six
months my friends have worked so hard
every five-minute coffee break at work
every night every weekend every spare
moment of their lives they gave to me if
I lose I'll never forgive myself you
deserve to win
we didn't volunteer to help you because
we wanted to wrap ourselves and personal
glory we did it because we care about
you you had a dream and we wanted to
support your dream that's what you do
when you care about someone you support
them win lose or draw let's go back to
the party
you drive I've had 11 whiskeys here we
go fire in the hole
whoa I gave you that as a gift on your
fifth anniversary as parts director you
told me this was a genuine partially
diffused claymore mine well it was I
bought the empty shell off of ebay and
then I filled it with you know balloons
and confetti and such you mean to tell
me I have had a toy on my desk for 10
years you mean to tell me you thought
you've had an actual landmine on your
desk congratulations Ron you've been
doing an explosive job come on Ron
what happened to these workplace
proximity associates hmm
spill it you left that a month later you
took Terry with you yeah well we needed
a mindless factotum and he's the best
there is a man then you took April I
didn't want her to go as she had become
one of my closest workplace
acquaintances but your offer was too
good to pass up so I didn't try to stop
her and Tom left to run his business
Donald left to run hers one day I looked
up I just didn't recognize anyone so I
made a decision an unthinkable decision
hey well my my my do my eyes deceive me
is that Ron Swanson hello Leslie
hello April Larry its Terry now okay as
luck would happen now did you talk to
Randy about the vote
tell the Northeast so we need to put
pressure on them or else we're gonna be
waiting forever and I'm tired of waiting
on them okay sorry this is a crazy day
so what's up with you you big lug
nothing important just thought you might
want to have lunch tomorrow
I would love to it's been too long JJ's
diner 12:30 excellent see you then okay
so Randy says the house is voting
tomorrow and they need us in Washington
to prep oh my god really
okay against the first flight out of
here and grab the Missouri files meet me
at my car hey babe I gotta go to
Washington can you pick up the kids oh
oh no Ron I stood you up for lunch you
did yes
I waited for a while but it was pretty
easy to figure out what had happened
your life seemed pretty hectic is that
the rest of the story that I stood you
up you were going to ask me something
that's why you wanted to have lunch Ron
you were going I was gonna ask you for a
job in the federal government just
saying it out loud feels dirty you
missed your friends and you wanted to
come up to the third floor and work with
us again I can't even imagine how hard
that must have been for you why didn't I
see that
Ron I am so sorry I should have been a
better friend to you honestly Leslie
it's fine
it was a punctuation mark on a sentence
that had already been written my time in
government work was over I'm sure I
loved shutting things down and bleeding
the rotting beast from the inside your
metaphors are so beautiful but it was
time for me to leave and I didn't feel
like explaining why to you or anyone
everything that happened after the fight
we had not given you a heads-up when my
company took on the Morningstar
development and bulldoze the nurses old
house I do regret that
I had a good run here but after you and
Tom and Donna and April and Terry left
when I looked around this office nothing
was the same yeah well there's a way to
fix that
[Music]
laughs with me but he just with me buddy
don't let her get the best of me but
don't ever let me start feeling lonely
[Music]
if I ever needed you buddy you know now
I really do but don't ever let me start
feeling lonely
[Music]
[Music]
well this is different from what I
expected to find
good morning Leslie what did you do in
the office Ron you're wearing my yoga
clothes are gonna stretch out the
elastic we're sorry
[Music]
you